well time magazine who you know named
greta tunberg person of the year
and she was a huge inspiration to me as
well last fall
time magazine said that your book would
be the most anticipated book
of the fall and that's the fourth
quarter of
one of the most momentous years in
history 2020. i was reading it
and i think that the way
you describe and humanize and humorize
um and the way that annie leonard
explains things in the back
for me reading it um
and i think greta does a good job at
this too even though she's so
intense and i feel like i'll never grow
up to be anything like her
you were able to put into words the
climate crisis that made it feel
like there is hope like there is things
we can do
yes we are running out of time but
sometimes that running out of time can
make people feel
disincentivized and want to run away and
hide and curl up into a ball
your book i thought was the way that you
worded everything it was like i felt
like i can do something
and there is hope here how did you
manage to hold on to that tone while
writing about something so serious
well there is hope i mean the scientists
who lay out the dire warnings
they all say but we can do it we have
we have the technology to do it we have
the money to do it
we have everything that we need except
the numbers of people we just need more
people we need about 11 million people
to be prepared to
put themselves on the line and and and
force this to happen
and we can do that is there a way to
talk to government
or voters that is incentivizing for
economics
and job growth and go that approach to
be
a country that is a leader in industry
of the technology of green you know
abilities
to change the world i is that
a smart intelligent way in that doesn't
feel divisive
um or alienating
absolutely you're right to look for a
way in that's not
alienating that's really smart drew um
the fact is that the green economy for
of the future
is more job-intensive there are millions
of jobs
that are needed to build electric cars
and trains and buses
and and and charging stations and a
smart energy grid and
retrofitting we're not resilient in this
country we need
resilience because more things are going
to come at us even if we started doing
everything right
because we haven't acted sooner the heat
that's baked in is going to
mean that for a while things are going
to get a lot worse and there will be
more pandemics
so our society needs to be resilience
resilience requires jobs
so what we need to do is we need to help
the workers that are now working
in the dirty industries in the fossil
fuel industries
to move into good union jobs in the
clean energy
uh sector what's standing in our way
well
fossil fuels and they're a biggie we
have to overcome the
influence that fossil fuels have on our
government
and labor big labor um
we we need to unionize the green sector
so that labor is going to support the
move of fossil fuel workers
from dirty pipes to clean water pipes
for clint michigan for example flinching
for example